В ефірі новини дня «heute»
з Барбарою Гальвеґ
і Норбертом Леманом.
Добрий вечір і ласкаво просимо
до перегляду випуску цієї середи,
Норберт Леман згодом поділиться новинами спорту.
Наші теми сьогодні.
Загальнонаціональні протести в Ірані:
після закінчення 40-денної жалоби за молодою Махсою Аміні
тисячі людей вийшли на вулиці проти
панівної ісламської системи.
Глобальне потепління загострюється:
ООН бачить прогрес у боротьбі зі зміною клімату,
але зусиль недостатньо.
Плани легалізації канабісу:
міністр охорони здоров'я Лаутербах хоче, аби придбання
та зберігання до 30 грамів залишалося безкарним.
Їх не залякати:
іранці вже кілька тижнів протестують
проти керівництва країни.
Особливо сьогодні,
адже рівно 40 днів тому Махса Аміні померла
в поліцейському відділку після того, як молоду жінку
заарештували охоронці порядку
через неправильно пов'язану хустку.
У всій країні люди вийшли на вулиці,
зокрема, на могилу Махси Аміні
в її рідному місті на півночі Ірану.
Репортаж Йорга Бразе.
Студенти медичного факультету в Ісфагані закликають до свободи.
Аналогічні картини в Ахвазі, в Мешхеді.
«Ви злочинці», - кричать вони силовикам,
які зайняли позиції на мосту в Тегерані.
Сьогодні таких відео чимало в інтернеті.
На 40-й день після смерті Махси Аміні її сім'я оголосила,
що поминальна служба не проводитиметься,
щоб уникнути неприємностей.
Ймовірно, це було вирішено під тиском влади.
Все ж натовп рухається до кладовища
в рідному місті Аміні - Саккез.
Подекуди в країні відбуваються
сутички з силовиками.
Режим продовжує відповідати батогом і пряником.
Вчора в університеті імені Хадже Насіра,
у священному місті Кум,
перед студентами виступив речник уряду Алі Бахадорі Джахромі.
За його словами, він прагне до діалогу.
Але його перекрикують.
«Ми не хочемо розмовляти з убивцями», - лунає у залі.
Знову і знову: «Жінки, життя, свобода».
Так, він теж підтримує ці цілі, каже речник уряду Джахромі.
Але у нього є відчуття, що він тут не потрібен.
Він сподівається, що в якийсь момент вони зможуть поговорити
в кращій атмосфері,
«але все, що ви робите - це кричите».
Сказав він і пішов.
Сторони не можуть розмовляти одна з одною.
І демонстранти цього теж не хочуть.
Для них більше немає підстав для діалогу.
Результат звіту ООН
незадовго до ﻿Всесвітньої кліматичної
конференції протвережує:
згідно з нею, зусилля нарощуються, але їх недостатньо.
Підвищення глобальної температури вже сягнуло 1,1℃.
І наслідки вже давно далися взнаки:
спекотне літо з температурою понад 40℃.
У Середземномор'ї - руйнівні лісові пожежі.
Третина Пакистану пішла під воду.
Навіть якщо всі попередньо зроблені обіцянки
будуть виконані, за оцінками ООН,
глобальна температура підвищиться на 2,5°С до кінця століття.
Попри всі проєкти.
Марк Гуґо розповість детальніше.
Навіть тут щось відбувається.
Мегаполіс Дубай збагатився нафтою.
Нині в еміраті будується найбільший у світі сонячний парк.
Амбіції щодо клімату зростають у всьому світі,
хоча цього досі не достатньо.
Про це свідчить новий звіт ООН.
Якщо всі поточні кліматичні плани будуть реалізовані,
викиди парникових газів у кращому разі можуть зменшитися,
проте глобальні температури все одно виростуть
на 2,5°С, як порівняти з 19 століттям.
Однак згідно з Паризькою угодою максимальне підвищення
має обмежитися 2°С, за можливості 1,5°С.
Для цього докладено замало зусиль.
Захист клімату відбувається в усьому світі,
але дуже й дуже повільно.
Ми все ще перебуваємо в ситуації,
коли уряди країн світу
не сприймають зміну клімату як кризу.
Це криза, нам загрожує екзистенційна небезпека.
Навіть планів Німеччини недостатньо, вважають кліматологи.
Але з метою стати кліматично нейтральними
до 2045 року ми на правильному шляху.
Німеччина має дуже амбітні цілі
і посідає хороші позиції на міжнародній арені.
Є проблеми з імплементацією, наприклад,
у транспортному секторі і те, що ми зараз
мусимо тимчасово збільшити використання вугілля.
Безумовно, це треба виправляти.
За 10 днів у Єгипті розпочнеться
Всесвітня кліматична конференція.
Як можна досягти кращого захисту клімату
в умовах енергетичної кризи?
І це, напевно, буде однією з тем.
Франко-німецькі відносини все ще напружені:
канцлер Шольц і президент Макрон хотіли
згладити ситуацію сьогодні під час робочого обіду.
Основним джерелом роздратування є енергетична політика канцлера.
Тому що він виділив 200 млрд євро у себе вдома,
аби впоратися з високими витратами на енергоносії,
але виступає проти європейської верхньої межі цін на газ.
Розбіжності трапилися і в питаннях оборони.
Тож це була важка зустріч,
навіть якщо прийом був дружнім.
Зазвичай після таких зустрічей завжди
відбуваються пресконференції, але не цього разу.
Анна Арендт наживо з Парижа, наскільки напружені
франко-німецькі відносини?
І справді, відносини між двома країнами
знавали кращих часів.
Те, що Еммануель Макрон і Олаф Шольц не змогли достукатися
один до одного для спільної заяви перед камерами,
роздратувало всіх.
Є перелік розбіжностей, які не вдалося
повністю відпрацювати.
Для розуміння того, в якому стані перебувають
франко-німецькі відносини,
важливо знати, що насправді планувалося сьогодні.
А саме, зустріч всіх міністрів в уряді за урочистих обставин.
Традиційне урочисте франко-німецьке засідання
Ради міністрів.
Однак захід було скасовано напередодні, натомість
відбувся скромний тет-а-тет, робоча трапеза удвох,
яка до того ж тривала досить довго - три години.
Дякуємо за критичну оцінку, Анно Арендт.
Уряд ФРН тривалий час сперечається
щодо участі Китаю в порту Гамбурга.
Попри серйозні масові побоювання
з боку кількох міністерств,
уряд вирішив: так, але з обмеженнями.
Зокрема це означає, що китайська державна компанія «Cosco»
може поглинути максимум 24,9%
контейнерного термінала «Tollerort».
Початковий план був на рівні 35%.
Це має на меті обмежити вплив компанії.
Наприклад, Cosco не матиме права вето на бізнес-рішення.
Канцлер хотів цієї угоди з Китаєм за будь-яку ціну
і взяв гору всупереч волі шести міністерств.
Шакунтала Банерджі з Берліна - тож якою ціною?
Так, ціна - це настрої в коаліції.
Напевно, так треба говорити,
тому що вони і раніше не були райдужними,
а зараз і поготів.
Зелені та FDP погодилися на компроміс,
але лише з гучним скреготом зубів.
Ми чуємо сьогодні від обох сторін,
що це рішення неправильне.
Міністерство закордонних справ зробило
спеціальну примітку в протоколі, що така угода
непропорційно розширить китайський вплив
на європейську інфраструктуру Німеччини.
Також зазначається, що є значні ризики,
і цю думку поділяє FDP.
Трохи дивує, навіщо Олаф Шольц це робить,
адже навколо рішення щодо АЕС
вже накопичилося невдоволення
його політичним стилем та комунікацією його відомства.
Зараз багато хто запитує себе,
чому це повідомляється саме так?
Чому напередодні лунають вирішальні заяви?
Проблеми, які постають перед коаліцією,
наприклад, захист клімату,
або питання, що робити з борговим гальмом у наступному році.
Тому питання, як нам разом повернутися до стилю,
який ми колись обіцяли одне одному, а саме - до спільних поглядів?
Щиро дякую!
В іншому питанні «світлофорна» коаліція переважно досягла згоди:
вона хоче легалізувати невеликі кількості канабісу.
Виключно для дорослих.
Перші плани для цього були ухвалені сьогодні на засіданні уряду.
Вони викликають суперечки не лише серед лікарів.
Критики побоюються тривіалізації препарату.
Репортаж Інес Трамс.
Канабіс - все більше молоді та дорослих вживають його,
і ця тенденція зростає.
За словами міністра охорони здоров'я Лаутербаха,
попередня заборона нічого не дала.
Тож час спробувати щось нове -
легалізацію канабісу.
Ми дійсно не хочемо розширювати вживання канабісу,
але ми хочемо досягти кращого захисту дітей
та молоді, а також кращої охорони здоров'я.
Усі регуляторні аспекти обговорюються саме задля цієї мети.
Ключові моменти, які сьогодні затвердив уряд:
придбання та зберігання від 20 до 30 грамів
не карається законом.
Дозволяється приватне вирощування.
Продаж у спеціалізованих магазинах.
Допуск з 18 років.
Мета - декриміналізація та контрольовані державою
ланцюги постачання замість чорного ринку.
Дистрибуція та вирощування мають контролюватися державою,
тобто ми прагнемо, щоб вся кількість, яка розподіляється
та споживається, була вироблена в Німеччині.
Лікарі критикують: ця пропозиція полегшує доступ до канабісу
для молоді, а не ускладнює його.
І їхній мозок піддається особливому ризику.
Чим раніше людина починає вживати,
тим більше шкоди вона завдає мозку.
Це може спричинити серйозні
порушення роботи головного мозку.
Психози, психічні захворювання,
які залишаться на все життя.
Отже, всі нюанси проговорили.
Однак законопроєкт буде тільки
після того, як Єврокомісія погодить легалізацію канабісу в Німеччині.
Перейдімо до новин міста Карлсруе.
Там Конституційний суд Німеччини
підсилив право на отримання інформації
депутатів Бундестагу.
Суд постановив, що державний уряд має інформувати парламент
також у питаннях європейської політики безпеки.
Вчасно та у повному обсязі.
Партії Зелених та Лівих подали позов до суду ще й тому,
у 2015 році їх вчасно не проінформували
про військово-морську операцію ЄС «Софія»
у Середземному морі.
Спортклуби б'ють на сполох.
Через зростання цін на енергоносії
багато клубів не зможуть обслуговувати свої приміщення.
Міністри спорту ФРН на їхньому боці та закликають
уряд їх підтримати.
Вони переконані: клуби мають продовжувати працювати
настільки довго, наскільки це можливо.
Адже спорт - це те, що гуртує суспільство.
А зараз це набуває особливого значення.
Репортаж Карстена Берендта.
Сучасна система опалення закритого тенісного корту -
гордість гандбольного клубу «Füchse» з Берліна.
Її вмикають лише тоді, коли корт здають в оренду.
Довго тривали дискусії,
чи слід цієї зими зводити повітроопорну пневматичну споруду,
адже обігрів тренажерного залу, душових та кабінету
також виходить не дешево.
За нашими підрахунками, наступного року доведеться платити
на 60-80 тис. євро більше.
Це жах.
Навіть попри те, що наш клуб великий,
ми все одно потерпаємо від наслідків.
Останні опитування показали:
5,6% німецьких спортклубів вважають,
що енергетична криза несе серйозну екзистенційну загрозу.
41,8% готуються до сильних наслідків.
Незначні наслідки будуть на думку 42,7%.
Криза не матиме впливу - у цьому переконані 9,8%.
Німеччина нараховує  87 тис. спортклубів.
Вони роблять цінний внесок для згуртованості населення.
Тож подорожчання, енергетична криза
цьому загрожують.
Спортивний клуб «Karower Dachse» також тривожить майбутнє.
Хоча у них,  як і в більшості клубів,
немає власного спортивного комплексу.
Вони зі знижкою орендують шкільний спортзал.
Електроенергію та опалення оплачує федеральна земля Берлін.
Вони сподіваються, що так буде і надалі.
У будь-якому разі
оплата не мала б лягти на плечі спортклубів.
Принаймні я сподіваюся, що це не трапиться в майбутньому.
Для того, щоб ми й надалі могли пропонувати послуги
за доступними цінами.
Ми не можемо допустити,
щоб наші клієнти платили значну частину.
Це не вихід.
Уряд ФРН повідомив,
що програма захисту від кризи
допоможе спортклубам.
Але невідомо, коли і як.
«Добробут тварин» - фраза, якою
торгові марки продуктів
приваблюють покупців.
Це означає: кращі стайні, більше місця, менше тісноти.
Однак це також залежить від того,
яких тварин взагалі вирощують.
Бройлерів часто розводять так,
що через обʼємну грудину
тварини ледь можуть рухатися.
Дисконтний супермаркет «Lidl» обвинувачують у тому,
що він допустив таке поводження з тваринами.
Репортаж Пабло Сілалахі.
Птахофабрика у Нижній Саксонії.
Вона постачає продукцію також супермаркету «Lidl».
Ці кадри таємно записали зоозахисники:
тисячі курей тісняться у невеликому приміщені.
Тварин такої форми у природному середовищі не знайти.
Щоб отримати якомога більше грудинки,
курей годують настільки, що вони не можуть встояти на лапах.
Вони не можуть дістатися до води.
І помирають у муках від спраги.
Це не поодинокий випадок.
Якби ми фільмували на інших птахофермах,
то бачили б приблизно однакову ситуацію.
Тому що вирощування тварин у муках -
стандартна проблема на птахофермах.
Lidl у листі звертається до ZDF та пише про намір
провести розслідування.
Мережа супермаркетів «Lidl» засуджує
жорстоке поводження з тваринами.
Ми серйозно ставимося
до обвинувачень.
Ми негайно ж попросили надати нам заяву
та організували перевірку незалежними експертами.
М'ясо зі згаданої птахоферми
продається під лейбом
власного бренду Lidl «Metzgerfrisch».
У рекламній брошурі дискаунтер пропонує
600 грамів курячої грудки за 4,49 євро.
Ціна за кілограм: 7,48 євро.
Для порівняння: органічна куряча
грудка в схожому супермаркеті
коштує в п'ять разів більше.
«Добробут тварин» також має свою ціну.
Тепер до «інноваційних» новин.
Йдеться про новітні технології, які виведуть наше суспільство
та Німеччину на новий рівень.
Таку інновацію відзначили «Премією майбутнього»,
сума винагороди - 250 тис. євро.
Кілька хвилин тому президент ФРН вручив нагороду команді,
яка сконструювала новий мікроскоп.
Репортаж Андреаса Лінке.
Кілька хвилин тому
президент ФРН Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр
вручив «Премію майбутнього» трьом дослідникам
з компанії «Carl Zeiss», що у місті Єна.
У 2014 році команда здобула Нобелівську премію
за розробку високоточного мікроскопа.
Однак актуальний проєкт
зробив значний крок вперед.
Проблема дослідників:
мікроскопи освітлюють клітини.
Це світло впливає деякі з клітин,
або навіть шкодить їм.
Ми відчували потребу у розвʼязанні
проблеми фотопошкоджень
для клітинної біології.
Однак тоді у нас ще не було варіантів,
як це можна було б реалізувати.
Сьогоднішнє рішення: дуже тонкі шари світла,
так звані Lightsheets, які освітлюють
лише місце, куди дивиться об’єктив.
З допомогою програми поєднуються окремі шари.
Лампа та лінза стоять під кутом одна до одної,
проте це створює нові оптичні проблеми.
Але їх вирішує мікроскоп.
Кадри, що показують поділ людських клітин.
З новим мікроскопом дослідники можуть спостерігати
«наживо» за життям на найнижчих рівнях.
Вручення «Премії майбутньої»
наживо на каналі «ZDF» о 22:15.
Але спершу слово тобі, Норберте.
Новини Ліги чемпіонів.
Два німецькі ФК показали вчора клас.
Сильна гра «РБ Лейпциг»
проти чинного чемпіона - ФК «Реал Мадрид».
Німці перемагають вдома з рахунком 3:2.
Це, до речі, перша поразка ФК «Реал Мадрид»
після 16 матчів.
«РБ Лейпциг» забезпечує собі місце у 1/8 фіналу.
Навіть після важкого матчу
ейфорія перемоги вселяє сили.
Я радий за хлопців, що вони вибороли нагороду,
що вони повірили в себе.
З перших секунд 45 228 глядачів
спостерігало за грою ФК «Лейпциг».
Нагорода не забарилася - гол на тринадцятій хвилині.
Гвардіол - центральний захисник відкриває рахунок - 1:0.
Менш ніж через 10 хв Нкунку забиває ще один гол.
2:0 на користь «РБ Лейпциг».
Незадовго до обміну полями
ФК «Реал Мадрид» зменшує відрив до суперника - 2:1.
Наприкінці другого тайму
в центрі уваги - Тімо Вернер. Він забиває гол - 3:1.
Намір Нкунку виявився марним.
Родріго забиває гол, остаточний рахунок 3:2.
До матчів плей-оф як рукою сягнути.
Натомість ФК «Боруссія Дортмунд»
завчасно вибився до 1/8 фіналу.
Завершивши матч з ФК «Манчестер Сіті» рахунком 0:0.
Герой вечора - Голкіпер ФК «Боруссія Дортмунд» Грегор Кобель.
На 58-й хвилині він блискуче відбив пенальті
нападника ФК «Манчестер Сіті»  Ріяда Махреза,
на якому раніше сфолив Емре Джан.
І таким чином забезпечує собі бали й вихід у плей-оф матчів.
Сьогодні зіграють ФК «Айнтрахт» (Франкфурт),
«Баєр 04 Леверкузен» і «Баварія»,
які вже кваліфікувалися до 1/8 фіналу.
Їхній суперник ФК «Барселона» у безвихідній ситуації,
потрапити до 1/8 фіналу команді
Роберта Левандовського не допоможе
навіть перемога.
Кульмінація зустрічі «Баварії» з Робертом Левандовським
набула нових форм.
Під час подорожі до Барселони зустрілися він і Томас Мюллер.
Леві, ми йдемо.
Не соромся, глянь сюди.
Перед початком сезоном поляк перейшов до ФК «Барселона».
А тепер йому загрожує вибуття із Ліги чемпіонів.
Ми ще маємо надію, але складно вірити у краще,
коли немає за що вхопитися.
тож сумніви зʼїдають з середини.
Матч ФК «Інтер» проти ФК «Вікторія» вже сьогодні визначить,
чи вилетить Левандовський з Ліги чемпіонів.
Як би не грав ФК «Барселона»:
якщо перемагає ФК «Баварія», то він стає лідером групи.
Усі матчі переглядайте з нами
у випуску «sportstudion UEFA Champions League» об 23:00.
А тепер - номери лотереї.
(на екрані)
Більше виграшних номерів можна знайти на lotto.zdf.de
та у текстовій версії ZDF, на сторінці 557.
Всі метеорологи обговорюють
незвичайно теплі дні.
Більше про це згодом розкаже Озден Терлі.
У heute journal о 21:45
вас зустріне Анна Ґеллінек.
А ми повернемося завтра.
Гарного вечора. До побачення.
Гарного вечора! Ласкаво прошу до погоди.
На нас чекає декілька теплих днів.
Причиною є антициклон,
який локалізувався над Центральною Європою,
та циклон на Атлантичному океані.
А ось цією «стежинкою» між ними тепле повітря рухатиметься
від Іспанії, Франції, а тоді до Німеччини,
і протримається там до неділі.
Стовпчики термометрів піднімуться до +27°C.
У центральній частині, на півдні, а також
на території Північнонімецької низовини
вночі утвориться туман.
Загалом буде сухо.
Найнижчі температури +12°C на заході
та +4°C біля підніжжя Альп.
Як тільки туман розсіється,
знову вигляне сонце.
Ось у напрямку Майна та на півночі
туман затримається.
Але пізніше також буде сонячно.
Температура повітря сягне
+24°C на південному заходу, +22°C на Нижньому Рейні.
У центральній Німеччині близько +17°C.
Протягом наступних днів
температура повітря буде підійматися.
У п'ятницю до +27°C - незвично високі температури.
У суботу +26°C, у неділю до +24°C та сонячно.
Гарного всім вечора!